non mais moi je et on l'a on va
certainement pas être d'accord moi je me
méfie de l'engagement politique surtout
pour un artiste quoique là la grande
dignité pour un artiste de libre toute
circonstance et bien sûr serait pas
d'accord avec moi et ça l'est surtout
surtout vis-à-vis de du site du système
communiste
j'ai fait comme un geek au voyage dans
les pays de l'est
j'avais pas très bien compris et j'ai
compris après la situation la condition
des artistes dans les pays de l'est
à condition de bien sûr d'accord avec le
vraiment est extrêmement confortable
infiniment plus confortable mais ce
qu'elle a ici un artiste sera à du lait
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours alors qu'ici
il suffit que suffit qu'ils cessent de
passer veille radio à la télé il suffit
qu'on parle de lui il suffit que qu'il
soit passé le monde pourquoi comment
qu'est-ce qui se retrouvent que sharp à
tiko là bas pas du tout c'est quelque
chose de marquer sinon véritable procès
finalement il a peu changé de voie et il
subit les bruits sert à rien leur
incomparable là bas c'est l'équivalent
d'un homme politique ou pas de problème